anyone who watches pen15 knows okay you
episode three you got to be ready
episode 4 episode 3 is fantastic it's
fantastic but it's an episode that
addresses will my your character
discovers masturbation and I'm wondering
that must have been very awkward to
shoot because I think the episode is
fantastic and I think it's handled
beautifully and I think there's just
there's great comedy there and it's also
very real and I think it would be great
for kids to see that show I really do
but at the same time I'm imagining you
with a crew they're shooting that
episode that because you were going for
it I was going for it yeah and it wasn't
it's not just one scene of discovering
masturbation there's maybe like 10
scenes and we shot you discover it and
then you rediscover and rediscover and
then you get yeah like all of us my mom
isn't and my real mom isn't it
but the firt we shot out of order so the
it was actually the first week and those
scenes were up all the guys have this
new crew that's just like they don't
know what show they're on I know I yeah
and then you know there's a girl with a
bull cut and a mustache and playing with
My Little Ponies and then rubbing one
out and they were like what am i
involving myself in like what is this it
wasn't sexy it wasn't no they probably
thought that police for coming at any
moment
so yeah it was and the fact that you
incorporated of My Little Pony was uh
I'm sure big I don't know if I it's it's
disturbing but that happens but that
happens that's like you get when you're
that age you get turned on by cups by
you know curves
in a table I don't know the smoothness
of this is like again I mean women are
very different very good cuz I don't
know what I know what I know what I was
turned on by and it was not cuff when I
can really great lot in that episode I
really